[inaudible]
we're partnering up with the [inaudible] ran institute this week and joining me
in studio or two of their top intellectuals,
terrorists,
Smith and Ancar.
Got Jay.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
We're going to be talking about selfishness and the virtue of selfishness.
How could selfishness possibly be virtuous?
I thought selfishness was evil.
Could it not be virtual?
I love love talking about selfishness.
Um,
I found the two most amount that you could possibly try.
I try and it's going pretty well.
And what I mean,
part of what I mean by that is
innocent.
You know,
it works for me.
It war.
If you want people to be happy,
I mean I'll give you one quick kind of capsule just to get us going.
If you care about people's being happy,
genuinely having fulfilling lives,
you know,
feeling good about their lives but with good reason to feel good about their
lives,
then I think you need to,
people need to think carefully about what's in my best interest.
And that's largely what selfishness is all about.
Doing what's really going to be good for you,
best for you so that you can have the best life that you can have.
I mean,
you're going to have to,
I can go on and on.
So that's why that's why we're here.
You may have to interrupt you
sometimes.
All right.
So on when I ran sort of first was writing about,
this was pretty radical to say selfishness was virtuous,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
I think it still is
in a weird way.
It may be more rather than
now at some level,
she's basically the only person who will say that selfishness is a virtue.
And people often say,
well,
look,
we obviously know that it's a vice,
you know,
all kinds of people that you label as slbs,
they're cheaters.
Um,
they cut corners in their work.
They're always trying to take advantage of other people,
and she has a completely different conception of what it means to be selfish.
What she thinks about those people is they're actually not pursuing what's in
their self interest.
They're not doing anything that's gonna make them happy.
Um,
and if you really took seriously that it's your life,
you have one life to live,
I'm trying to make the most of it.
You would not act like that.
And I think even more important,
the way she thinks about it is that we bundled together into the concept.
So the idea of selfishness.
So the used cars salesman who's cuts corners,
you should put the odometer back in and he's trying to cheat as customers.
We put that together with a Bill Gates who's labeled as selfish because he makes
oodles and oodles of money,
but he makes it,
he doesn't steal it.
He doesn't cheat his customers.
He's often a tremendous of value.
We call a kid who wants to just play with his toys and doesn't want to share.
Maybe he's saved for a year to buy a bike and now he wants to use it.
And someone who hasn't done anything that comes by and you're,
well,
he doesn't have a bike.
You have a bike.
So you're supposed to share like why?
And we put all this together.
All these people are selfish.
Yeah.
And some of these people are bad.
And some of these are profoundly good.
You can't think with that kind of concept of a very good vocabulary for bad
behavior.
So we just throw it all,
oh,
it's all selfish.
Well,
no,
not if you're really thinking about what is in your self interest.
Now a lot of that behavior is bad and should be condemned.
But because it's inconsiderate or non objective about the other person or
abusive in some cases,
I mean there's all sorts of bad exploitative behavior and iron ran is certainly
against that.
But doing what's good for you.
And sometimes that means turning away the appeal of somebody else.
You know,
we're oh,
but this person needs it.
Or this other person is more important than you.
It's like,
no,
my life is the most important thing to me.
Just as yours should be to you and just as yours should be to you.
And in fact,
that's really the only path by which people can lead the kinds of fulfilling
lives and rewarding lodge and genuinely good lives.
So one of the things that I really like to do on the show is,
is defined words,
because especially these days,
we live in a time where everyone's sort of defining words or ideas their own
way.
So partly what we're talking about here is a sort of misunderstanding in a
modern sense of what the word selfish means,
right?
That how,
what's the best way,
if you wanted to lay out what that other person is,
the used car salesman who's not really,
they're acting selfishly at some level,
but that,
but they're really not would be iron rods argument because they're not doing
what's in their best interest by cheating their customers.
It's probably not best for them,
right?
In the laundry room.
Well,
I'm not sure that there's always going to be a term that's,
you know,
a single best term to use for some of these cases.
Iround advocates,
what she calls rational selfishness.
It's gotta be thoughtful selfishness.
It's gotta be about what really is in my interest,
not just long term,
but longterm.
Not just today.
What's going to make me feel good now.
But all things considered.
I mean,
think about,
for instance,
when you go to a wedding and you wish the young couple,
all the happiness in the world,
right?
All the success in the world.
You go to college graduation and you hope they have a really successful life
that's good for them.
All right?
You're thinking about,
I mean,
it's not that you hope they'll do whatever will make them feel good.
They'll get the right drugs and they'll just be,
you know,
there'll be dumb and happy,
but they'll think they're having a good life,
right?
So the used car salesman,
the cheater or the philanderer or some of these,
these creeps,
right?
I mean,
they've gotten into relationships that then they're cheating on their wives or
whatever it might be cheating on their clients.
Um,
is this for,
I mean,
if you step back and actually think about it a little bit,
is that making them genuinely good life,
a genuinely satisfying life?
I mean,
you'll read about the Madoffs who were wracked by not just guilt,
but hating themselves the entire time there.
You know,
engaged in the kinds of games that they're engaged in.
It so it's not,
I think that there's always going to be a single team.
Now again,
in some cases it is something like that was really inconsiderate of this,
you know,
and sometimes it's a smallish thing or that really non objective.
You weren't realizing well from his point of view and where he stands,
he had good reason to be concerned about this and you had good reason to be
concerned about that too.
Yeah.
Just one broader point.
Sure.
While I do think some of this is about what we mean by the term,
it's,
it's not just all ran to saying what everybody else is saying,
but she's using the word a little differently.
I mean she is saying no radically different from just about everybody else who
talks about ethics.
You know,
when she was writing today forever,
your life is yours.
You should make the most of it in a way that's respectful of the fact that
others lives are theirs and so on.
But to do that you need to be focused primarily on the value of your wellbeing
to you and trying to think about what's really going to put together a compose
that mosaic that is the best life for me.
So would it be fair to say that acting in your own self interest is the most
sort of,
it's sort of the best way you can live if personal responsibility is of primacy
to you?
If,
yeah,
if personal responsibility and your own life.
So I think another way of thinking about that she's advocating selfishness and
it's not the only term she uses as Tara was saying.
I mean rational self interest is another one and another one is the pursuit of
happiness.
But really taking that seriously and means the pursuit of your own individual
happiness,
that that's what you should be aiming at.
And part of,
I think what she's,
when she's trying to reclaim the term selfishness,
I think part of the way it gets a bad rap is people are presented with a false
choice.
And the false choices,
either I give up my values,
the things I really care about,
the stuff that makes me happy for the sake of other people or else they,
I'm so I'm so I'm losing and they're gaming apparently it or else it's I
victimize other people and the ideas I'm somehow gaining by that and they're
losing.
And those are your two choices.
So you can be selfless without a self.
And then you were sort of like a patsy and you give up everything for the sake
of other people or else you're selfish.
And that means you're exploiting and taking advantage of other people.
And she says this is a false choice.
And I think that's really important to get it.
And both are not selfish.
So if you're really thinking about your self interest that neither is the way to
pursue it,
right?
So there has to be some kind of third alter and what she's putting out as a
third alternative that you can live a life that you're aimed at your own
happiness that's radically non exploitative.
So you don't think of other people as prey.
So I'm glad that you mentioned the term self lists,
which seems like the reverse of selfish because it seems like we live in a time
right now where with all the virtue signaling and everything that's coming out
of this sort of social justice warrior crew that there is,
there is a facade of selflessness as if they're doing all these things to be
selfless.
But I would argue they are doing it probably because of some deep need within
them.
It may not be scratching that itch but,
but how did the idea of selflessness becomes so thought of as so obviously.
Right.
Well that goes way back.
And I will say,
I don't think that,
you know,
to separate discussion,
but I don't think that all of these social justice warriors or whatever you want
to call something,
I don't think they're all necessarily seeing themselves,
that a lot of them are seeing themselves as virtuous.
I think some of them are virtuous.
Um,
I don't think they see it all in terms of being selfless and there's some real
good that can be done for certain causes,
but that's a separate issue.
Uh,
you know,
I mean,
think of Christ,
think of scripture and certainly other religions and other philosophies have
this as well,
but you know,
it's due for God or do for your other,
you know,
I am my brother's keeper.
Alright.
Um,
there's something greater than me.
I mean,
the individual,
the you as you as often just from religious traditions been,
no,
no.
You know,
you are a lucky retch that God loves you.
and if you're lucky,
if you earn salvation,
how do you earn it?
By serving others,
by serving the Lord,
by serving.
So it's sort of been drilled out of people just for centuries and we,
meaning it goes back in that sense.
Yeah.
As to people that,
that do this for a living and get in and out of these ideas,
what,
what techniques have you found to,
to take a young person who's been so taught that either being selfless is the
right thing to do or doing for others is the right thing to do and putting
yourself second year where the greater good,
all of those phrases you have any tricks to kind of wake people up to,
to some of this?
I'm not sure it's exactly a trick,
but I think there's a question that,
um,
it's not easy to ask and you can help people ask,
which is why,
hmm.
So why do you have to do these things?
Why is it that the nation counts more than you?
And so you're asking where this comes from?
Yeah.
It has deep,
deep,
uh,
origins I think in religion.
And even prior to that,
when you look in philosophy and it goes,
it's for centuries and centuries.
If you just think of the,
the Republicans and the Democrats,
would,
you basically can take any president in his state of the union when he's trying
to say like,
this is morally what you should do,
live for a cause greater than yourself,
greater than your desires.
I was George W.
Bush asked not what you can do at what your country can do for you.
Ask what you can do for your country.
So there's always this kind of conception that there's something higher above
you.
It can be God,
the nation you're raised and so,
and your obligations are to that and to sacrifice what you why.
So that's,
and we'll know it's,
and it's uh,
yeah,
I think it's that so important because these ideas of selflessness and serve as
our so taken for granted.
People don't know why they're supposed to think about,
they know that they are,
we know it's like,
Woo,
this is what I'm supposed to think.
But everybody thinks this.
Everybody respectable,
everybody likable,
everybody good,
everybody decent.
You know,
so,
but it is this article of faith much more than a product of reasons.
So,
I mean,
when you trying to do with anybody,
it's a get them to start questioning.
But I think another thing sometimes it's helpful is think about some of the
concrete virtues.
Um,
you know,
think about honesty and how that might be self interested really or justice and
how that might be self interested or certain alleged virtues.
Maybe arm with our cracked up to be,
if you actually think about them in very specific kinds of circumstances.
And that's something I know that with students,
you know,
they can relate to the justice of dealing with roommates who don't pull their
weight around the house and do the dishes when they're supposed to do the dishes
or whatever.
Yeah.
Right.
So just being selfless in that case,
in always cleaning up after your roommate would not be the wisest thing for now,
nor your room or the other roommate or anyone involved.
I've got,
right.
It would be stupid.
You'd be a pattern.
No,
I mean what most people,
and you were speaking of the three alternatives,
well,
I'm either going to exploit you or just be a sucker.
Right?
Right.
And Miranda's offering a third alternative.
But in a sense,
I think of it sometimes as a fourth alternative because another alternative that
most people say,
well of course you got to be selfish sometimes.
Of course you're not stupid.
You know,
you got to take care of yourself,
you got to go to the doctor or whatever.
And but of course you got to put others first time.
So it's a balance.
You meant,
you know,
you play exploiter SiTimes I mean that's their version,
right?
And what you're saying,
this is,
it's not a zero sum game morality,
having a good life.
If you become happy,
God bless you.
I don't believe in God,
but you know,
he got the form.
I mean,
that's good.
That's great.
That's no,
that doesn't mean he can't be happy.
That doesn't mean I,
I,
there's no zero sum there,
but
right there,
I guess there's the idea that somehow if you're selfish,
that that precludes other people's happiness,
that you're just going to run him shot at the world when it's street seems to be
in reality that things today that I don't think that a damn thing to anybody
else.
You know,
you know,
I do exercise this morning,
left nothing for on are never good to good,
good snacks,
Huh?
Yup.
I mean there's much that we do to try to take good care of ourselves,
you know,
on a,
on a regular basis that has nothing to do with winning off other people or
anything like that.
But again,
if you're really thinking about what is a person's wellbeing,
what is in their interest?
If you're really thinking about that as opposed to,
well,
we've got these throwaway lines about it,
then you have to start taking seriously what might be
so is that the key part of this then?
Then most people just don't think these things through.
So if you ask the average person while,
are you selfish though?
Might say no.
If you've attacked them and then if you,
but if you really widdled it down to,
well,
how do you live your day?
Do you mostly do things that make your day go well,
basically be it at work or at home or anything else?
They usually they'll say yes if they're living somewhat of a decent life.
Yeah.
And I think part of what happens with what the demonization
of selfishness,
it's part of the whole split that there's morality and there's practicality.
So you can either be moral or practical,
or as Tara was saying,
it's sometimes you want it to be moral,
so you're going to be selfless and give up things.
But most of the time we wanted to stop this practical and pro my life and,
but it's putting a completely different category.
And what I ran the saying is it's hard to be practical to really devote yourself
to your life.
And if you do that,
it's moral.
And so she's a uniting to things that most people,
she would a party.
That's the most moral thing.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
And it's hard.
That's part of what's different in Oregon
exceptions here again,
that you don't,
one of the characatures of selfish,
you're just saying do what you want to do,
do whatever you feel like doing.
Now again,
think about that.
Try that for a week.
I'm not going to study for the test.
I don't feel like it.
Yeah,
I'm not going to go to the dent.
I don't hate going to the dentist or the,
you know,
I mean live that way.
Oh,
I don't feel like thinking about what I can actually afford and how much money's
in the bank and say,
yeah,
see how that works out for Ya.
I mean,
no,
it takes thought and think about,
I sometimes use these examples of where it's really clear you want to do what's
best for you.
You're trying to decide which college to go to.
Let's say you've decided to go to college.
Okay.
You know,
there's a range of considering how much does it cost,
how far away is it?
How good are they in the subjects I'm interested in?
Um,
you know,
there's,
right,
what's the culture like at that college is too big.
Am I gonna you know,
there's a lot of stuff to way where even though the objective is I want to do
what's going to be best for me,
that might be clear.
Unequivocal in your mind doesn't mean it's a no brainer.
What's gonna be best for you people and people face.
That's just one example.
I mean,
you know,
medical treatments in some cases,
should I take this job?
There are a number of cases where it's not transparent.
It's not always easy.
It's sometimes takes discipline to,
you know,
beyond that Palio Diet or make that marathon and trained for it and so on.
So we're not saying just always take the shortcut or something like that.
Right.
I suspect,
yeah.
If you remember when Mother Teresa died years ago,
that they said that on her deathbed she was realizing that she wasn't as happy
basically.
And,
and then she had had doubts all along.
I suspect that wouldn't surprise you as someone that tried to live for others
all the time.
Um,
yeah,
I think she had,
when you read some of her diaries and some doubts about what she's doing,
I think part of the doubts are it's,
I've given up everything and there's the big question of why is there's really
no reason to do it and you need to event a god and all the particulars of it
that the God wants you to sacrifice and give up your things and it's,
you don't have any reason really to do it.
You've never been given a reason yours.
It's,
that's part of what the faith is that I'm going to subordinate myself to this
higher alleged higher power hype and it's a live a life like that.
You're going to have doubts.
Did Andre ever link any of this to just how we're wired that if you leave some
people to their own devices purely that they will do some of the shady or
selfish stuff?
Let's say that it's not just that because not everyone operates in a purely
rational way of thinking all the time.
Do you know about it?
If there was any connection to that.
I mean I wouldn't put it as,
it's exactly wired,
but it's sort of a default in that it's a real achievement to think.
So just to think and engage and think what is right and wrong,
what is true and false.
That's an achievement.
It's not.
You have to do something rotten.
Most people do that automatically and you have to be doing something wrong.
That is a positive achievement that a person has to choose.
And if he doesn't choose to do that,
then I think there's all kinds of defaults that he's going to follow.
What other people do?
He need some kind of guide and he's not in this idea of self responsibility.
He's not his own guide.
He's not figuring out what to do.
So the typical thing is to look to other people and that easily then can become,
you're sort of living for other people.
They're telling you what to do.
It's the authority and taking order kinds of things.
And it leads to,
so she has a lot from that perspective,
I think.
But she thinks of it as a sort of default of you've got this tremendous capacity
that you could choose to realize and you could make something of your life,
and if you don't,
then there's all kinds of things that that happened.
Doing your own thinking is one of the major virtues that she talks about.
She talks about it in terms of independence,
but it's,
you know,
you've got to do your own thinking,
learn from and be open to,
and you can learn tremendously from others,
but you've got to think it all through for yourself,
whether it's on moral issues and how I should leave my life or what I should do
or whatever.
That's actually one of her part of central selfish virtues is doing,
do your own thinking.
Try to understand for yourself so that you can make good decisions about what's
true,
what's real,
what's right,
what's moral,
what's gonna serve my wellbeing and my hat.
Yeah.
Are you guys particularly enthused at this moment for some of these ideas?
Because when I hear you say that about people thinking for themselves,
I mean,
you know,
I'd like to think I'm a little part of something that's happening online right
now where people are doing it doesn't mean they're all objective,
isn't sure or anything else of course,
but there does seem to be a resurgence,
especially amongst young people and when I've done events with Ari,
I meet all sorts of young people who may be agree on this or disagree on that
and they're every color and race and sexuality and all of that stuff.
Better thinking again,
and I don't know that if I was doing this exact thing say 10 years ago,
that it would have been as influential or effective.
Yeah,
I mean I think it's a very positive sign that there's these,
I mean are you do long form stuff with deep conversations and it gets a big
audience and eyes are,
yeah,
and I actually think that part of what's going on when you're thinking
predictive of the young people,
it's this is what they expected college to be more like.
And unfortunately college is like that anymore.
Yeah,
it was I think more when I was still a student undergraduate student than it is.
And so this deep exploration of ideas,
ideas I haven't encountered before,
I might not agree with,
but it takes work to even just listen and like what's this other perspective?
And let me think about it in this space to think and you're not supposed to just
fall into lockstep with everybody else.
Yeah.
There's too much of that now.
Um,
so I've been the fact that you can't,
you've got an audience in other people.
It's a really good,
are you seeing that someone that's teaching young people,
are you seeing sort of a resurgence of an interest in ideas?
Somewhat.
I mean,
even though I'm at a big university at the University of Texas,
um,
I often teach small classes and somewhat selective honors classes often at
least.
Um,
so it's,
in that sense I can give you,
you know,
the most representative a spectrum,
but I definitely see,
for instance,
I've had free speech dialogues for several years.
I was hosting these sorts of things and just as encore was saying people were
students,
all sorts of students attended and really responded positively.
Again in the sense that they really seemed like they wanted to engage with
different ideas.
And I do think you're right that 10 or 20 years ago there wouldn't have been as
much interest in hearing other ideas.
But I think it's just the bankruptcy of the reigning philosophies,
the reigning political philosophies and moral philosophies and the fact that the
selflessness,
you know,
really be selfless and serve even though that's still,
you know what you're supposed to think of when everybody says how long can you,
I mean you have to cheat on that in order to actually live,
you have to be prudential or practical is Ancar was saying,
right,
how long can people cheat and people are,
I mean enough people and often young people are honest enough with themselves to
realize maybe we need some different broader theories here about what is good
and bad and maybe there is more to be said for self interest or,
yeah.
So you both mentioned morality here.
So let's try to link selfishness to morality.
So obviously you can just look at America.
We live in a country of,
I don't know,
350 million,
some odd people who have all sorts of different moral beliefs.
Yeah.
Does that then complicate a society's ability to operate in a selfish way?
Because people have,
people are,
they're bedrock of moralities starting in a different spot.
I think it does.
Um,
so if you think back to the founding of America,
you need,
it's not everybody has to agree with this,
but you need a significant minority who thinks that the pursuit of happiness is
it good thing to engage in.
And you can have different conceptions of all the details of what that
happiness,
consistency and the five founding fathers were creating a system.
What's your free?
Um,
and so you have an enormous amount of latitude of how the kind of life you're
going to build and so on.
But if there's,
if you really have a perspective that it's a sin to pursue your own happiness
and to exhibit a,
so another one of mine runs virtues,
pride.
And Pride is,
is it about making something of yourself and you can,
I mean,
put it very colloquially,
you can look in the mirror and have a moral approved,
like I'm morally good to have that and that that takes work to achieve that.
If that's regarded as a sin,
then I think the whole system political system that the founding fathers
designed,
there's something deeply problematic about it.
And what you saw in the 19th and into the 20th century with the rise of fascism,
communism,
various forms of socialism I think was targeted at,
it's selfish to pursue your own happiness and it isn't.
Yeah.
I mean freedom is what's,
you know,
once you're talking about a society of an organized political society,
I mean,
what allows people to have great variations in the gods that they pray to or
whether they pray at all in the mortalities that they practice?
What allows that is a common commitment to individual's freedom.
But that's in compact.
I mean,
truly this was one of the things that I ran.
You know what's really,
I think insightful on,
you can't defend that idea that your life is yours.
And you have a right to it.
If you think,
oh no,
it's not,
it belongs to this God or that God or these people or societies like the,
so no wonder we're losing freedom again.
That's another political con conversation to have.
Right.
But no wonder when will the underpinnings,
the moral underpinnings or,
yeah.
I'm being lost.
You briefly touch on the phrase rational self interest.
Do you see any,
is there any distinct difference between rational self interest and selfishness
or is it just another way of saying,
oh,
I just seen them as the same.
Yeah,
know true.
Genuine selfishness,
I mean is,
yeah.
Yeah.
Do you think that,
so that's a little bit of a branding thing,
right?
I mean if the word selfish,
this is going to scare a certain amount of people.
I think rational self interest sounds maybe a little more palatable to a certain
amount of people.
Yeah.
It's parked
Brandon and I think it's important that she's in the sell idea,
right?
I mean,
she didn't only use selfishness,
she used rational self.
She used pursuit to happiness.
So it's not like she's saying this is the term you have to use.
Don't use any of these others.
But I think she's using selfishness to be deliberately controversial,
deliberately provocative,
but in a very deep way.
And that goes back to some of what we were talking about that people's attitude
disorders,
we know it's selfishness means you don't to iron rent.
And her perspective is exactly the reverse,
right?
I know what it means.
You don't,
you lump all kinds of people together under this rubric selfish and they're so
different.
And some of these people are good and some of these people about you don't
really have a concept of what selfishness means and this is how to think about
it properly and that's what she's trying to do in the book.
So it's deliberately provocative,
but there's a deep point about like,
I understand this better than you do.
Yeah,
I
know.
And people think the reverse.
So that,
that's a good segue then to altruism.
How do we fit in?
How much should you save do for others?
Because a certain amount of people are going to watch it.
So these guys,
I get it.
Okay,
but what are they doing for other people then if they're just doing things for
themselves all the time,
which to get to that,
that definition,
that more narrow down options.
Uh Huh.
Unselfishness.
Yeah.
Well
rand and I agree with her completely opposes altruism by which I mean,
you know the elevation of others above oneself,
you know,
up the valley,
presuming that there is greater value in another person or the need of another
person trumps my life,
my needs,
my values.
Right.
That's what she's against.
Now that's not the same thing as being against ever helping other people or
certainly not against,
but now again they think,
oh,
you're just a
solid system isn't even the word I'm looking for him.
You know,
you just,
you don't like other people or you're antisocial.
No,
not are you kidding?
Again,
think about,
think about your life.
I don't know about you,
but I love p they're individually.
I think that's little bit,
get to know them a little.
You know,
you get to know some people that goes away.
But would you,
is your life better?
I mean just broadly again to start,
right?
Is your life generally better because about people good things.
They came up with fantasy football.
I came up lot.
I mean there's like a reason.
I mean they came up,
don't get me started,
but uh,
you can value other people.
You can have very different kinds of relations.
I mean there are some people who will become good friends.
There's some people you'll love from it.
I mean,
my God,
you're in love with this person.
I mean there are people who you just like for,
you know,
as a tennis partner or as a student or we have all sorts of relationships and
then there's,
there are circumstances in which it makes sense to do things for those people,
but not as a sacrifice.
Not at the expense of,
okay,
I'll give it to him because he needs it now.
Damn it.
I'm not going to get to do that serious thing I've been wanting to do and saving
to do.
And so that's what she's against.
Yeah.
Self sacrifice,
putting others first.
But there are men,
one of the things I talk about,
I have a book which talks a lot about Rand's version of selfish virtues.
And I have a section in there where I talk about generosity and charity and
where they shine it because they're not virtues for her,
but nor are they.
Thou shalt not,
you know,
oh my God,
that would be a mortal sin.
And you know,
how can,
oh,
Tara,
you're going to be excommunicated.
No.
So there are circumstances,
shoes in and of themselves,
but they're,
they're not obligations.
They're not standing obligations.
You know,
when the opportunity arises,
you must give.
Yeah,
sorry.
no,
I get it.
I get into it.
No,
I think that,
that,
that's really interesting.
Um,
I mean,
yeah,
that was good.
So you were asking a little bit before about,
um,
thinking of this from a more biological perspective.
And I think part of the way she thinks about it is,
so the whole issue
of fact in value comes from biology.
So when you think about living things,
you think about them as having values.
That is some things are good for them and some things bad,
some things beneficial,
some things harmful.
And that any living thing I'm going to plant,
if you don't water it for two weeks,
is that good or bad for it?
And everybody has this perspective while it's obviously bad for it and any
living thing you look at like that.
And it's true of human beings as well.
And it's how you should look at your own life.
That I,
there's values in the world that I have to pursue given that I'm a human being,
but the,
the selfishness as exploitation,
the idea is it's dog eat dog.
Um,
and that's what she's rejecting completely.
And I think this is what's radically different about human beings that we're
capable of trading.
And so whore principal,
she calls it the trader principle.
It's the you,
you should be giving value for value with other people.
So you should seek out other people.
It's not just,
okay,
they happen to be here,
so I'll go talk to them.
So seek out,
there's all kinds of values you can,
you can learn from them.
There's companionship and there's trade.
And specialization.
And so I mean w w civilization we live in,
well you couldn't live in like each person on a desert island.
I mean it's ridiculous,
but there's a vast,
vast difference if you're dealing with someone where you're both profiting from
the relationship or only one person is.
And if it's,
if it really is win,
lose whatever the direction,
it's not a good relationship and we're capable of having win,
win relationship.
That's particularly interesting to me cause I think a lot of people think you
can't have a win win situation.
I think a lot of people think in the terms of if I'm getting something okay,
yeah,
as if there's a finite amount of something I have to be taken and I will now
have,
we're different.
Human beings are different,
right?
We're not just like animals.
We have to scavenge and oh no,
there's only so much meat.
And if this wolf gets it this one long or something,
it's like,
no,
we create values.
And this was obviously,
well,
as anybody who's read red nose major theme,
it's our mind,
our use of reason that enables us to create the values,
not just find them somewhere.
Oh,
good.
Got there first.
Right.
Create the things that we need to survive,
to flourish,
to enrich our lives,
to make our lives so good.
Right?
And so,
uh,
I'm going to get,
and you just think of some of your best relationships now again,
that starting with your best relationships.
Right?
But hopefully I don't,
I don't know if you're married or what your situation is,
right.
But it's pretty when hopefully it's good for the two of you,
right?
I mean,
we're friends.
Yeah.
I think it's good for the two of,
you know,
um,
[inaudible] I mean,
there are all sorts of relationships.
Again,
less person,
not the best one,
but,
uh,
you know,
not just to focus on the very best ones where,
hey,
this is good.
This guy likes being a butcher.
I like his meat or wouldn't,
you know,
whatever it might be.
Yeah.
Think how bizarre it's there.
There's this common view that love is selfless.
Think if you really try to spell it out,
and this is,
you were asking like for four tips for people ask what?
Like what does that mean and why is this true?
It is.
And what are we really mean is you're in a relationship with another person and
you would be telling them like,
I don't get anything from this relationship.
I don't really know why I'm in it,
but you seem to be benefiting so that it makes it good.
Right?
So are they in that way too?
And then,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean if it's,
and you can't,
when you really projected you,
it doesn't make sense.
Um,
and when she talks about trade,
so she means it both in economic and material values,
but also spiritual values you gain from being around good people and gain in a
way just not do like in your pocket book.
It's exactly right.
I think sometimes the word trade does have those narrowly economic connotations
and it's not like,
oh,
you calculate how much you get.
You know,
the more good successful people are around you,
the richer the pool from which we all have to benefit.
I mean,
I will write just all,
you know,
thinking of another natural win-win.
That's great.
If the woman who wrote all the Harry Potter books is richer than Midas or
whatever,
she bought a hell of a lot of pleasure and so on to other people.
Right?
I will frequently write an author if I really liked there where I might be
fiction or whatever,
you know,
or a singer or performer.
I really like,
that's great.
You know,
she's getting the accolades or she's getting the money in.
I really enjoyed this book or that concert or so it's win win.
That's,
I see it as a,
uh,
an application in a way of justice of respecting what I think somebody desserts.
Like,
wow,
that was really,
that was out of the ordinary in my view.
So I just want to tell them that lots of wind went out there.
So when someone says,
well wait a minute,
uh,
j JK Rowling has made hundreds and hundreds and millions of dollars and nobody
could possibly need that much money.
She didn't get it because she needed it.
She got it.
Cause people wanted to,
they fought.
I'm better off.
I want that book.
I actually haven't read those,
but I've been reading her mysteries,
which I liked very much.
So there's a plug for you now.
Yeah.
But um,
let's make that woman out of the money.
Yeah.
Look for thing.
Hey man,
she worked hard to do that.
And at war and it's,
and people want it so they want to pay.
So it's
right.
If you think about the question that which he has more money than she needs,
that only seems like the criticism if you have the zero sum.
So it's,
she's amassed so much and that means other people are losing out.
Yeah.
But what he should want if,
and again this is,
if you're selfish,
you should want everybody doing what she's doing.
Yeah.
Like you should want more people like that.
More people like Bill Gates.
More people like Steve Jobs.
I mean,
think of how Steve Jobs transform the world.
What the iPhone,
it's [inaudible] would you like?
You want to get rid of him?
Are you on 10 more people like him?
And,
and just from the perspective of your life and you're benefiting,
it's for sure.
I would rather have 10 more than try to take him and then discourage these
potential 10 upcoming.
Because look,
when he gets really successful,
which is what happened,
Bill Gates,
so we're going to go after it,
right?
It's,
it's in their interest to be free like that.
But it's in my interest to be,
yeah,
right?
Because everyone wants to be that person.
If you're living in a sense of like,
you want to do something not because necessarily you just want to be rich,
right?
You want to do something that has value.
Right?
So it's interesting.
Let's try to bring this into a little bit of what's happening right now.
You know,
there's all this talk about taxes now and Alexandria Ocozzio Cortez talking
about the 70% marginal tax rate.
And I saw this really interesting Twitter thread where someone took,
uh,
the rock.
They said,
you know,
Dwayne Johnson,
he makes you know,
$250 million a year.
And then they tried to break it down what it would look like if he was having to
pay all these taxes and the kids,
you know,
over 10 million,
then it's at 70% and basically after this long Twitter thread,
they got it down to something like even if he's making 250 and we taxed them out
of the Wazoo,
who made $35 million a year and who couldn't live on that?
And I just was reading it,
I thought I'd put it.
That just doesn't make it right.
Makes you kind of feel good.
So we sort of outsourced our brains on this in a way.
Well I think it,
it,
it's theirs to the,
to feeling good about something that has nothing to do with you or something to
that effect.
But it's,
it's,
you're making him sacrifice,
you're making him give up values for other people and that's supposed to be
good.
So they think of it as they're doing something good,
but it comes from a view that selfishness is wrong.
And being selfless is right.
And if someone's not going to be do it voluntarily,
we're gonna force him to do it.
And I mean,
um,
which is directly correlated to just that
state power and the role of government,
which obviously I ran,
talked about a lot too.
Um,
what about some of this is just that we live in a way in a society where we have
outsourced our virtue so that,
you know,
it's like if the government does everything and the government takes care of
poor people,
where do they do it well or not is a separate issue that we don't have to do
certain things that perhaps if we lived in a society that was a little freer,
we might actually do more and feel good about it.
Well,
we'd have to think more.
It goes back to some of what we were talking about much earlier in the
conversation.
I think.
Um,
yeah,
there's a lot of outsourcing of conscience,
um,
both to the government and to just society in general.
Like there's a sense in which it's easy to be the altruism of the selfless.
You say all the things that all the respectable people say,
right?
You get variations of those you were reading or mentioning some of the kinds of
things that state of the Union addresses or commencement addresses.
All right,
so you seem like one of the,
you know,
one of the with it guys or whatever.
Right?
So whether it be we outsource it to government to,
well yeah,
I have a guilty conscience,
so tax me so that I'm fulfilling my duty,
but then I can still go by the person I want to buy or whatever it might be.
Again,
all we see are,
you know,
are we serious about,
do you want to be a good person?
You got to think about what it is to be a good person.
But from the more positive end too,
I think you want to be happy and you think you think it's a good thing for
people to be happy holes again,
you know,
like if you are okay then we have to seriously think about how you're going to
get that.
How is anybody going to be happy?
And I know for me one of the real turning points as I was discovering
objectivism and,
and coming around to yeah,
there's self interest,
you know,
on the right understanding and her is really good is when,
when it clicked for me and yet I had been thinking about it in a while.
Like you can't make other people happy.
This,
I think this is really important.
There's also things you can do for other people and that that can be of
substantial,
serious benefit to other people.
Right?
But I can't make you a happy person.
I can't make you fulfilled.
I can't make what it's like to be you feel good to you feel fulfilling,
feel rewarding,
feel like this is a life worth.
I can't give that to you.
Even if I look,
if I know you really well and I let her do everything,
you know,
there's more to say that,
but it's like,
but if that's the case,
then the only way for anybody to be happy to have the best life,
they can have this for them to go after it for themselves.
And that's going to take,
again,
really thinking,
maybe I'm inclined,
there are circumstances in which you know your rich uncle can pay for your
tuition.
I mean,
they're right.
You can be the good friend who really listens and tries to understand and you
know,
I mean,
so there are a variety of ways in which we do benefit.
Again,
we were talking earlier about relationships is potentially real wind winters,
right?
So there are all sorts of things you can do,
but you've got to know what somebody else can't give me.
You know,
at some it's like,
ah,
that comes from,
let's say I'm learning chess.
Okay,
quick example,
you're teaching me chess and now it's the first time I'm actually going to go
have a match with this guy over there,
right?
And you're like,
in the room feeding me all that,
you know,
you're telling me everything to do and I do,
and I beat him.
Uh Huh.
Am I gonna feel good?
Am I going to be learning anything?
Like,
am I really getting ahead?
I won.
Right?
But it's like,
so it's some,
I mean,
that's a rough analogy.
You gotta do it for yourself,
you have to lead your life.
And you know,
thinking about what's gonna make me fulfilled,
happy,
feel good,
you know,
what's actually going to be me using my resources,
my capacities and growing and self realization and all that.
That's a kind of thing somebody's got to do for themselves.
They could still have great relationships with others and that can be part of,
you know,
them building their good lives.
So a lot of those that comes down to the right way of parenting probably too,
which is that you just want to give this person that you brought up into the
world the right tools so that they could go ahead and figure it out for
themselves and to really encourage handing them a bag full of yeah,
problems are all
fixed and
you know,
do whatever the hell you want to do.
Yeah,
and I think it's the parenting and wider education.
I mean we're both teachers and it's,
we both know there's a lot of things you can do to help students learn.
But if they're not putting in the work,
there's nothing.
You can't shove the knowledge into their mind.
And if we're thinking about valuing as it requires a lot of knowledge and of
really thinking things through,
is this the right career for me?
Is this really worth doing?
Is this producing a value?
And having a firsthand view about that,
you can't shove that into who's head he has.
You can help him see certain things,
but they have to do a lot of work and you're trying to encourage them and show
them like there's an end result that's really positive,
but they have to put in the work.
And this is the,
um,
both,
I think I ran thinks a two virtues as virtues don't,
it's a moral traits of character that most people don't.
They might think of him again as practical but not as more.
And that's,
you need to be rational,
which is really think things through for yourself.
Don't be too quick to just agree with everyone else.
Do I really understand things and to be really pursuing and loving knowledge and
then to be making stuff to be producing and I think that's the most distinctive
and it goes back to this,
she views life as trade.
When you're interacting with people you can create new values and if to go back
to the Cortez,
the 70%
she's seen as moral because she's going to take somebody else's money and give
it to somebody else and the guy who's created it is not seen as moral and he has
no say about what happens to his money.
Yeah cause he made it here cause I already did the dirty work
but somehow no,
no this is moral.
This is,
Oh yeah this is the higher ground than we should all be on.
Will it also see at some of the,
I suppose comes down into that a certain amount of people think that they can
control the universe or or or something to that effect.
Right.
Like she's trying to build a system that if she could only build her perfect
system,
we would all behave in the way she wants us to.
[inaudible],
which is [inaudible].
There was a word for that,
right?
Not Polite to say of of you know,
Saint Cortez.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
we just opened the youtube comments of,
Hey,
let's link this dough to justice.
As long as we're talking about Cortez,
and you mentioned justice before.
Not everyone that watches my show knows how frustrated I am with the social
justice.
But as you alluded to earlier,
there are,
it's not all first off,
I would never argue that it's,
it's totally a mountain 10 short.
Most of these people think that they're doing good.
I think they're ultimately what they're creating is not good.
But where does justice,
well,
I guess,
how would you define justice and where,
where would it fit into this conversation?
Justice is definitely one of the central virtues and rans of selfish
virtues.
Um,
she says justice is a matter of judging other people objectively and treating
them accordingly.
So it involved.
So you know,
couple of parts to that,
right?
It does involve judging people as opposed to judge not and be not judged or who
are you to be judgmental or who do you DJ and all that.
No,
no.
You have to judge individuals,
right?
People always say,
don't judge me,
but when I do this ridiculous,
you have a suggestion and notice that if you're good,
you're not going to say,
don't judge me.
But if you're
crazy,
judge.
Right,
right,
right.
But it's again,
judge objectively.
So you have to go by the evidence,
right.
And sometimes you don't have enough evidence.
So don't judge prematurely.
Don't be like,
oh,
I gotta reach a judgment.
I don't know enough yet.
Or I don't even have to go or whatever.
So you have to judge,
judge objectively and doctor accordingly.
Treat the person as he deserves.
And Yeah,
so it's definitely a virtue.
It's a virtue.
Again,
it's an application of being rational,
as uncle was talking about earlier,
to be realistic about people.
People vary in many,
many different respects.
It's not just a matter of judging their moral character,
right?
I have to judge my mechanic.
She,
every time I bring the car to that guy,
I always have to bring it back three weeks late or whatever.
Right?
Or this place charges too much for whatever it might be.
You judge roommates again,
uh,
you know,
college roommates,
whenever Conrad,
who should I,
who should I have to babysit the kids?
I mean,
we judge people for all sorts of things.
Minor,
major,
you know,
very consequential or not.
It makes sense for your own self interest to try to be very clear eyed in the
judgments that you make.
And you know,
I'll give my business there or not,
or no,
I'm really interested in that person.
Let's see if she wants to go out Saturday night or whatever it might.
So you judge people,
you treat an objective.
When we
live in a society though,
where people have a different moral bedrock and I know that even though you'd
love for everyone to live by these rules,
obviously you're not going to impose it on them.
I know that much.
Um,
how do we get a consistent definition of what justice is then?
as a society,
I think it has deeper foundation.
So it,
it end,
there has to be some agreement on those deeper foundation.
And again,
not every single person has to agree,
but you don't if,
if you have on the foundational issues in a,
in a society,
everyone disagreeing about everything,
you can build a call.
You don't really have a culture,
you have a clash,
um,
uh,
an ideological clash.
Right.
And I think the base of the sort of,
yes,
yes.
And I,
and I,
I think it's,
it's because there's various competing issues.
They're still the enlightenment heritage of viewing people as individuals and
that they have control over their lives over there thinking in action and I can
therefore judge them as individuals.
And that justice
is an issue of judging individual by individual.
You can have blanket,
um,
and collective when we're talking about moral judgment that all blocks are all
gays.
That there's no such thing.
If you're really thinking of guys and the more you have and can at the deeper
foundations of the culture,
the more it's pushing that what your identity is,
is your group.
And it can be different groups.
And the more that your conception of justice is totally different because you
don't think of it as an individual in control of their lives and have to judge
individual by individual.
And if there's not agreement about that,
like if most people think no,
we're just these group,
right.
The tribal 70%.
Right?
Yeah.
And this is tremendously what's happening right now.
I mean this is what I would say,
the sort of oppression Olympics of judging us by those traits and looking at
somebody and going,
you have darker skin.
So I should think this,
right?
You're a woman.
So I should think this.
I mean this,
this seems to have become mainstream thought right now.
So it's funny when I've had,
you're on Brooklyn in a couple of times,
he'll talk about how well when he goes to eastern Europe where they're starved
for ideas because they've lived through communism,
will they love iron ran because they need a,
a little more individual
uptown,
just a few and nothing like your own,
um,
a few eastern European countries and,
and spoken there.
And yeah,
the reality of the alternatives is more palpable to these people,
even younger generations,
but they remember their grandfather's farm and you know,
the do it all because it did not have a free or economy and so on.
It's all much more real to them.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
I think we've definitely kind of socialize the idea of justice.
Justice is an interesting virtue in that it goes way back and many different
cultures,
eastern West have very strong ideas of justice and many of them are essentially
this idea of you're treating people as they deserve,
but it's gradually over the years been distorted and ideas about individual
desert.
Oh,
dessert.
No,
no individual can deserve anything.
You know,
you are with the community made you,
you are just,
you know,
it takes a village,
you didn't build that God forbids like kind of did in some cases.
You know,
it is the individuals who did,
but it's a sort of a transposition of the anti individualists that's really
perverted justice in some of these ways that we're seeing.
So this has been a through line through everything we've done here.
But let's just bring this to honesty also and why honesty is so important.
It's again,
I think she has a very distinctive view.
So most people think of honesty back,
linking it to selfishness,
that if I were to be selfish,
I'd be dishonest because I'd explored other,
I lie to them.
I cheat.
I tell more
than one story.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And so that's what's selfish.
But honestly,
well,
I tell the truth and I'm interested in the truth for other people and rans view
than I think it's that it's really important to get that this is right is you
should care about the truth for yourself.
So you should be horror.
Conception of honesty is a passionate commitment that I want to know what's true
about my life in the world.
Jen,
if I'm in a bad relationship,
I don't want to fake and pretend that I'm in a good relationship over.
I've never been to get to be in a good relationship,
right?
If I don't face the fact I'm not in a good relationship,
I don't like my job at war.
Right?
Buckle on Facebook will think you're happier than you are.
And that's true.
That's true.
And that's,
I mean,
if you're really have a conception of is my life,
I've got one to live and so on.
It doesn't matter what other people think about it and if they think you're
happy or they think you're not,
it's okay.
You know,
from the inside you have a perspective on your own life.
Is it going well or not?
And part of honesty is to look at yourself in a deep way and think,
do I like everything about myself?
Um,
are the things that I don't,
things that I can improve.
Do I like my situation in life and thinking about happiness of I'm in a dead end
career or I've exact like I liked it,
but I'm so now just going through the motions sort of I need to change.
And the,
the,
if you pretend or fake,
what don't,
you don't gain it.
Anything you don't,
you're still in this new job that you're not really fulfilling.
You're pretending to yourself and maybe other people because you have to be
respectable and you kind of have a midlife crisis or whatever.
But if that's what's happening,
you should really face it.
Yeah.
I mean,
the way I think of it often is,
is just faking things doesn't change things.
You can pretend to other people or to yourself,
right?
But faking things doesn't change things.
So the sooner I figure out what things are and like face that honestly,
the better position I'm in to pursue my happiness.
You know,
to,
to have a good life to get out of this really like,
and a lot of it is avoiding self deception.
I think that's really important.
It's not just a matter of are you honest with,
do you tell lies?
Right?
It's like
the road to hell is paved with evasion of fudging or Justcan,
you know?
Yeah.
You gotta be honest with yourself.
You've got to be honest.
You got to try to face facts and find out when you don't know what's what so
that you can make the best decisions.
Right.
So faking isn't going to help.
But again,
what's interesting I think is usually when people are taught well,
you gotta be truthful.
You gotta be honest.
Because the reasons given are when you get a bad reputation.
If you're found out to be a liar,
right?
Your credibility will suffer.
People won't want to deal with you.
Or in general,
this is bad for the social fabric of trust,
but you know,
we needed a lot it.
Well now that those most things are both true.
Mm.
But one solution would be become a better a lie or don't be found out,
right?
It's like,
no,
that's not really going to help because more fundamentally than what other
people think or your dealings with other people.
If you're alone on a goddamn desert island,
I don't want that old movie castaway or so I'm like,
you gotta be honest about it.
I've got something here that I think I should worry about or I think there's a
storm coming this way.
I've got to follow the facts,
right?
I got to track the truth if I'm going to make rational decisions.
So it's a very reality based approach to honesty.
Yeah.
Faking things doesn't change them.
You can lie on the CV and pretend you,
you can do something that you can't.
Good luck when you get in the job then you know,
if you can fool people for awhile but you can't fool reality.
And then are there moments where being dishonest is actually within your
rational self interest?
I wouldn't put it as dishonest,
but if you have two concrete,
a view of what honesty and dishonesty mean then.
So are there times when I would lie?
Yes.
Um,
if I'm in the kind of standard examples of this fifth,
some gang is going around killing people and they ask,
well what does your wife or whatever I'm going to lie,
right.
And,
and I don't view that as dishonest.
So if I think of honesty,
his loyalty to the facts,
it's,
oh,
okay,
okay.
And dishonesty is,
I'm trying to get around the facts and trying to achieve something wild,
getting around the fact I don't think you can achieve.
So you can try to put just people off the scent for him an in line to them.
And I think there was situated,
I mean that's the standard kind of,
I think there are other situations where I would lie because I did.
Someone's trying to invade your privacy and so on.
And if you just say no comment or something like that,
it,
it's often better if you lie and they go off looking in some direction where
they should.
Um,
so there are situations,
but I don't think of that as it's honesty is about,
I'm loyal to the facts.
I want to know because I need knowledge in order to guide my life and to succeed
in everything that I'm trying to do.
And I think even when you think of it in regard to other people,
the reason you brought a Bernie Madoff before who lied on left,
right center,
um,
why does he feel out of control of his own life?
And when you read that,
it's because,
as Tara was saying,
he knows that he's lying.
So these are not facts and the liar typically thinks I'm so sophisticated in a
good liar and these are all idiots who can discover any facts.
But the facts are out there to discover and you know,
that and some so viewed longterm,
someone's gonna find out the way he's cooking the books.
And the more his scheme goes on,
the more things there is to find out.
And he knows that any experiences and massive that he's out of control because
he is out of control.
Right.
So basically I was building a house.
A car.
Yeah.
And that other people might,
the one that knocks inadvertently.
Yeah.
He tells somebody like he has to keep his five different stories straight and he
told the wrong thing to the wrong person who then starts to question.
And that's like inevitable in the situation because the facts are still,
they're out there for people to discover it doesn't make it.
So,
yeah.
So that's an interesting way to link to the final topic that we'll talk about,
which is pride.
So you may say pride cometh before the fall.
He must've thought made off,
must've thought I can manage all this stuff because of these people.
As you said,
they must be idiots and I can manage all right.
But it was his pride in a way that was almost his downfall at some level.
Well,
he's,
well he's,
I would say his fake pride or,
yeah,
that's the,
that's I think the big so not is authentic presence.
Yeah.
I think it's,
yeah,
we're,
we're coming from,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's good.
I'm not taking care of the right virtue of pride in mind,
but that he had this here concocted a system.
Yeah.
In his mind that he felt that he is superior to everybody so he can juggle this
and so on and he's capable nobody else's.
And so,
but that is just,
that's such massive self deception.
I think there is no reason to think that.
I urge you to just think of the investment world.
There's all kinds of people like a Warren buffet and so on who are hoarding like
orders of magnitude,
a better investor than made up.
If you were really thinking about this,
no way you could think that I'm,
I can do everybody about everything.
And there were rumors over lot of long period of time of people who understood
that there's no way that hit the scheme is the Tragile Jalynn's I might not be
noticed specific fraud,
but there's no way and a lot of smart money to be true.
Yeah.
A lot of smart money invited him into it and that like that's a fact that it's
so there's such self deception going on and pride is about um,
developing a character that's good and therefore you can respect and he's doing
exactly the opposite.
He's expecting someone that he can look in the mirror and when you read about
the account,
it's more and more he feels like that,
that,
and it just trying to put something over on others.
And that's where he's seeking his self esteem by.
Oh,
what a good,
clever guy.
Right?
Yeah.
Ran Talks about pride as a verb.
Right.
I used to pride go,
you know,
we're told,
oh,
you know,
pride is one of the seven deadly sins.
She says it's one of the,
you know,
the six or seven major virtues.
What she talking about.
She's not talking about patting yourself on the back,
you know,
it's not the self congratulatory,
Oh,
I'm a wonderful,
you know,
get,
get ready for my closeup.
Pride is about mate.
Well,
she describes it as moral ambitiousness,
which I think is one of the loveliest phrases in her nonfiction writing.
I'm trying to be the best person you can be.
You,
you referring to making your character.
You know,
we talk of a self made man.
He made his fortune or j k rallying made her fortune.
You make your character,
you can make your character as good as it can be,
not as an end in itself,
but so that you can have the best light.
Hey,
I want to really live according to the principles that make sense for human
happiness,
for human beings to have rich flourishing lives worth living.
I want to do it.
So if I figure out what the right principles are,
I want to practice those.
You Bet.
I want to be perfect now,
perfect or not.
You know,
everybody freaks out and you say the word,
but I want to be as good as I can be.
You know,
when I'm 22 years old,
when I'm 28 I have different capacities and so on at different times.
So it's make your life as good as it can be.
Be Morally ambitious.
Dot means again,
you gotta be honest with yourself.
It doesn't mean you excuse.
It's like,
no,
no.
If you realize,
oh,
Tara,
that was not,
I was not too good.
You've got to be honest.
If you really care about your character,
your life being as good as it can be,
but that's what she's talking about.
Yeah,
you should be proud.
You should feel good about yourself when you've earned that.
Aristotle said,
same thing on that part,
you know,
he said,
yeah,
pride is the crown of the virtues.
When you practice all the other virtues and can honestly look at yourself in the
mirror,
but what it's about is not this gaze and it's not comparative.
It's not all.
I'm so much better than him.
It's I want to make my life as good as it can be.
I want to be morally ambitious
and if that's a pretty good,
it's pretty good.
I'll make one like that too.
[inaudible] to me and then,
and then we locked guys [inaudible] here.
All right.
Just to look at it back from the perspective of the moral in the practical.
This is when she's saying they go together.
Most people fear morale,
lead or suspicious of it because they think of it.
It's there to take their values away.
It's uh,
it's the rock.
He's made 70 million and now,
well,
to be moral you would give 70% of it away.
And so,
and what her whole conception is,
no,
you live it to the fullest.
So pride is both its moral and practical and you're trying to unite these things
together.
So instead of fearing morality,
you're interest in it and you want to learn its principles because it's going to
advance your life.
It's such a radically different view of thinking about morality.
That is a salad ending,
my friend.
All right,
well it's me.
It's been a pleasure chatting with you guys.
Thanks for watching everybody.
Remember,
this is just one in a series of six of these interviews that I'll be doing over
on the iron ran institute youtube channel,
and you can find a link to that right down below.
[inaudible].